Vintage video games have become more popular
than ever as older generations of players
seek to revisit their old after-school activities,
and newer gamers want to see if Bayou Billy
was really that difficult.
Most video games aren't worth a whole lot,
but there may be a few buried in your closet
that are worth a few bucks.
We'll skip the ultra-rare exclusive stuff
and focus on games you may have just picked
up at a store back in the day and have actually
played.
Since values always fluctuate, these prices
are based on information from the date of
this video, so future viewers, your experience
may vary.
We’re also focusing on loose games, because
only nerds keep their video games sealed.
Sealed and complete games, with their boxes
and manuals included, often command even higher
prices than the ones mentioned here.
Start digging through your collections as
we go through this treasure chest of valuable
games!
Stadium Events, U.S. Version
As the rarest commercially-released NES game,
Stadium Events only hit a few stores in 1987
before Nintendo pulled the game and re-released
it with its new accessory, the Power Pad.
The new game became World Class Track Meet,
which was coded to work with the new motion
controller pad.
It’s rumored that only about 200 copies
of the original Stadium Events sold before
the rest were destroyed, so those that have
been found are worth up to $10,000.
Before you get too excited, only the US version
is rare.
The UK's PAL version, with the white, oval
Nintendo logo, is pretty common and isn't
worth as much; the US version, which features
a circular Nintendo logo, is the one you’re
looking for.
Copies of this crazy rare game are still known
to pop up at thrift shops, so keep your eyes
open and your legs limber.
The Flintstones: Surprise At Dinosaur Peak
By the time Surprise at Dinosaur Peak was
released in 1994, gamers were already three
years into the life-changing Super Nintendo
Entertainment System and had mostly lost interest
in 8-bit gaming.
Not only was Dinosaur Peak one of the last
NES games to be released, but after 27 years
of reruns, interest in The Flintstones wasn't
exactly hot during this time either, despite
ridiculous attempts to revitalize the franchise.
If you happened to be a devotee of either
dying home consoles or caveman hijinks, you
may have hit the jackpot.
This game sells for around 650 bones today.
Little Samson
Another game released around the end of the
Nintendo Entertainment System's lifespan,
Little Samson saw poor sales in 1992, and
wasn't noticed by players until many years
later.
In addition to being rare, it's one of the
few valuable games that's actually a lot of
fun to play, with critics comparing it to
Adventure Island and Mega Man.
If you have a copy, it’s worth around $900,
but most authentic retro gamers will never
know the pleasure.
Outback Joey
Before the Wii Fit tried to get tubby gamers
off the couch, there was Sega's Heartbeat
Personal Trainer, a rare variation of the
Sega Genesis console which incorporated movement-based
controls instead of the usual gamepad.
Only one thousand Heartbeat Personal Trainers
were produced, and each came bundled with
Outback Joey, a game that monitored your heartbeat
to control a kangaroo.
Decades ahead of the obesity epidemic, the
Heartbeat Personal Trainer missed the usual
gaming audience and remains relatively obscure.
Outback Joey still slipped into a few collections
and is now worth around $1,950.
Air Raid
The vast majority of Atari games don't have
any real value today, but if you have a copy
of Air Raid for the Atari 2600, you have a
piece of history.
No one knows how many copies were released,
but only 15 have been found, and the company
that produced it, Men-a-Vision, never made
another game.
Boxed copies of this UFO-invader game have
sold for over $30,000, but even loose carts
catch around three thousand.
The cartridge's unique color and shape could
help it stand out from the local flea market’s
unending bounty of tube socks.
Most Atari games aren’t worth the plastic
they’re made with today, but there’s at
least one more exception to the rule…
Eli's Ladder
If you really want to make bank, build a time
machine, and use it to buy weird and educational
video games.
Eli's Ladder for the Atari 2600 is another
rare example of a valuable Atari title which
originally saw limited sales, mostly because
it taught math instead of making things explode
with spaceship lasers.
Today, a copy is worth around $1,500.
Its developer, Simage, never made any other
games, but the one they did make left a huge
impression on collectors and math-challenged
children.
Magical Chase
A side-scroller starring an adorable witch,
Magical Chase was released at the very end
of the TurboGrafx-16's production in 1993.
While the game was good enough to be re-released
on other platforms so that everyone could
enjoy it, collectors are still willing to
pay up to 4,000 dollars for the original release,
which sold poorly during its initial run in
stores.
We’re not blaming Bette Midler for ruining
witches for everyone, but…we’re blaming
Bette Midler.
"I put a spell on you!"
The Legend Of Zelda: Majora's Mask, Gray “Not
For Resale” Version
If you were friends with someone who worked
at a Toys "R" Us back in the early 2000s,
they may have been sent home with a copy of
Majora's Mask from their in-store Nintendo
64 demo machines.
Unfortunately for gamers, most of these demo
games were incomplete prototypes and only
designed for a few minutes of in-store play
at a time.
Fortunately for your wallet, many modern collectors
are completists, and Zelda fanatics are typically
even more intense.
Copies of Majora’s Mask that are both grey
and bear the ‘not for resale’ label can
be worth up to $1,300.
Working retail never looked so rewarding.
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
rare games you’ve found in your closet...